I'm very happy with my data again trying
to push my message of ours and fighting
can play nice together so about me my
name is Linda I'm a physicist by
training I like my space drinkie rather
than loopy I'm moving to data science I
went from on-demand services nearly caps
to now fashion and I work as a data
scientist at lists elsewhere I'm very
much into ballet books drawing and
photography I have a ballet website the
body bag calm so shameless plug and I've
been using Python since the late 2012 so
so that's me in a shop a nutshell so
let's let me give you some motivation
and I'm gonna start with this xkcd comic
because I love xkcd and who doesn't like
xkcd so the first frame we have a
survival call and a hazard rate quest
and we unfortunately this is a quite sad
comic because it's talking probably
about some cancer diagnosis and it's
basically listing the survival
probability so it says basically a
there's an 81% survival probability for
an individual to live up to five years
and 77% up to ten years so they talk
about probability being a favorite
branch of math because it has many
real-life applications so the main point
of this talk is to convince you that
actually this set of techniques is very
very important so let me give a very
brief intro survival analysis is given
to the name of statistical techniques
that have to do with analyzing the
timing of the events which namely this
is duration data and its relationship
with covariance now traditionally this
has been the realm of medical
researchers and actory so lots of
insurance they ensures they have to be
able to estimate you know how long
people are gonna live how long before
they have an accident
etc how long before they get sick so
typical are what is expected lifetime of
patients given treatment a what is life
expectancy in London but it's also
widely used in engineering to look at
failure and mechanical systems namely
reliability theory
but survival techniques have many
applications in the industry so typical
questions might be why does the time
between sign up and first order use when
will a customer churn
how long before tweet has no effect when
will a store run out of product how long
before a person replaces his or her
phone how long is the career of a
football player
why does the expected lifetime of a
stocking Game of Thrones
so these are very very different
important questions at least I've been
involving using survival analysis in
mainly in a project involving prediction
of out of stock products and you're
gonna be hearing a lot about list
elsewhere because there's several lists
speakers in this conference so instead
of me going and talking about fashion
I'm gonna be talking about basically
first I'm going to argue that survive
analysis is very useful set of
techniques that can be used as part of
the standard data science pipeline this
is acquiring cleaning storing and
modeling second I'm going to expand on
techniques to evaluate survival
functions via random forests and
generalized additive models I'm going to
keep advocating the use of Python on our
according to the use case in hand and
finally I'm gonna show you explicitly by
applying to a real data set drumroll
please
academic careers so the make question
I'm interested today is what is the
average lifetime of an academic career
and you might ask well I'm interested in
this particular question well I was an
academic myself so and lots of people
came from academia into data science so
another comic from PhD comics said you
guys have done a PhD you'll probably
familiar with this comic strip so post
up versus postdoc so survive but before
we start and going into academia let me
just give a very very quick skim through
what I call survival analysis 101 so
some definitions first the first event
is the time associated with the
beginning of an observation period that
that event is the time associated with
the end of an observation period either
by an event end of the study or
withdrawal from it and then censorship
we don't know we see the Advanta core so
you're thinking of medical studies you
know the studying my end before people
will die or
other type of thing happens so the
current time or other events will censor
us from seeing to that vent so this is
an example so the basically there's days
from the start to you know six thousands
of long long period of time so the read
observations they're the points
signified that events and then the blue
ones is basically individuals who
haven't died and basically this is a
particular sample from my academic data
set that I'm going to explain and
enlarged in the song so a survival
function looks like this this describes
the probability that the system will
survive beyond the time T is basically
this probability and the survival time T
or at that time may be thought as a
random variable so basically at the
beginning of time well chances that
you've survived are is one and then as
time passes by that probability
decreases monotonically another very
interesting or an important function is
the hazard function so the instantaneous
hazard rate describes the probability
that event T of course in T plus delta-t
given that the individual is live at t
and i know that this is a bunch of
formulae but the most important thing is
the bottom-line relationship between
what is going to be the cumulative
hazard function which is just the
integral of that lamda and the survival
function which I presented before I'll
leave this at the slides for your
reference and well the question is if
you have any of the disk curves you'll
be able to say a lot about the you know
the population itself you'll be able to
say hey you know the median lifetime of
this population is X years or X days and
you'll be able to say well you know by
this point this is the number of
failures that I've observed or I have it
sorry microphone so there's some ways of
giving an estimate of the survival curve
or this hazard a cumulative hazard
function so the first one is the
kaplan-meier estimator it's a non
parametric and non-parametric oh gosh
that's a mindful maximum likelihood
estimate of the survival function it is
a step function which jumps out of syrup
event
so if si represents all the individuals
that have died at time t i and RI is a
risk associated from these individuals
in this period of time then you can
basically compute this and it will look
like a little rack like her which will
be a very good estimate to the survival
curve and likewise the Nelson Allen
estimator is an equivalent formula for
the cumulative hazard function so okay
so that was like a very very quick you
know roundabout through survival 101 so
now I'm gonna be going into an actual
use case namely surviving in academia
so let's first explain what is life in
academia for all you know people that
haven't been in economic so people go on
to a PhD and then they might do a
postdoc then they might do another
postdoc they might do another postdoc
they men do another postdoc and then
some of them might get tenure those have
survived for a long time others will
probably die on the pathway so they
interesting thing about this problem is
first how do I get a population for
which I can apply these techniques and
basically answer this question because
how can we define I mean there's not
like a unified database where I can go
out basically say oh individual a this
is the name they did their PhD started
this year and that this year it's all
over the place and then depending on the
area PhDs might be longer or shorter
part time so there's many many variables
there but at the end of the day you're
an academic you're probably gonna be
publishing research papers so these are
going to be the events signaling if a
person is still in academia and now we
have online repositories and portals so
many papers can be found as electronic
preprints and in particular in many
fields of mathematics and physics all
scientific papers are self archived so
if you if I go and decide to pick an
area where basically they all polish
papers as per prints online I'll be able
to piece back all the lifetimes of
individuals that are continuously
publishing because their economics
there's also open access digital
libraries that combine literature
databases with author metadata so I
could potentially also get additional
covariance in terms of affiliations you
know where they're publishing the papers
if they do this with other people where
where these people in which institutions
they are etc so it's a very very rich
database so in my particular case
because I did physics and I know that in
the high energy physics field we
basically always put papers on the
archive or print system then I have a
very very high confidence they'll be
able to know if a person is still in
academia or not
now authors that have published a
preprint in the hep th which is the
Hydra physics theory archive you're all
very welcome to go and explore you
because there's an API available and
basically what I'm going to do is to
subset all offers his first paper was
between January 2010 2015 and they have
more than two papers so this is the
rough idea I'll be explained with more
detail as I go and this is just a very
very snapshot of a very very horrible
function that basically just signifies
get data from the hep th physics repo
start and they ant and they just dump it
on a CSV and then just give it back so
at the end of the day I got I KJ normal
Zeta frame where I can see all the
titles of the papers the abstracts the
authors for names turning the categories
when it was created because of course it
can be republished and the ID and the
DOI if you later made it to a journal so
that's okay and this is just something
interesting so this our number of
persons per year now the archive started
I think in 1992 so although there's a
couple of papers that appear before but
very very few so you can actually see
these little bars but you see this is
like increasing so a lots and lots of
reference of course there's cross
listings but I'm not going to get into
that game at this stage and then this is
also a Allah
plot of the author's first paper so
basically counting how many first papers
appear in each year of course because
2006 hasn't finished you have taught
that drop at the end but you can see
there the behavior
now I also need some covariates to
basically be able to model you know what
basically makes people leave academia
and what are the factors that influence
a long lifetime in academia is it that
you manage to do your PhD in a good
institution you see that you published a
lot is it your gender etc so the first
thing is well I'm gonna try to get some
additional metadata and for that there's
the expires portal which also has an API
and you can also get all the information
for a given name you can get their
affiliations you get the number of
papers or coiffeur so you can get a very
very rich set of data the small print of
courses that beware of authors names
because how people go and write their
names for the paper unfortunately is not
consistent so if you have two names if
you sometimes put accents or not
depending where you are you might be
identified as different people even
though you're the same individual and to
be first bars works a lot to try to be
able to Qualis all these results but
there's some you know errors as expected
so there again there's a very snip
snapshot of the type of options you can
pass through the API you can get all the
information in JSON back you can
basically extract more information that
I would actually got but in this way by
first getting all the author's name from
from the archive then I just make a huge
pickle of authors and then I just go and
call this API and get all the metadata
for those authors so this is the raw
output so I got data for over 25,000
authors there's of course many issues
with date involving consistency of names
affiliations missing values etc but then
for a given author I can basically list
all possible ovulations
work which was her first institution the
paper the number of authors when was the
first paper published and the foolish
things so this is just a very very small
example
and then of course you have to go to the
whole issue about data cleaning and a
pain particularly was the affiliation
cleaning because again it's a matter of
names so for instance you can have this
list of affiliations and here you can
observe Oh King's College London and
then King's College London main and then
King's College London Department maths
and this is for the same individual and
if I don't do anything I would count
this as three affiliations when actually
it's just one so you need to find a way
of really cleaning this to something
that is much more consistent and they
just
Qualis these three results the other
thing of course is that sometimes people
might be visiting another institution
and then they might put multiple
affiliations on the same paper so that
makes a problem a bit more complicated
but but anyway that's a subject for
another talk on cleaning data and
parsing strings but this is the type of
thing that we need to do in order to
acquire data for survival modeling so we
need to extract time stands for first
and last paper calculate the durations
and determine if the observation is
censored did that how I define the time
on which I was gonna decide to end my
study was based by a based on observing
the average publication time across my
population so I realized that actually
there's times in which people go over a
year and a year and a half without
publishing so then I had to allow for
some time to be able to decide oh this
guy has definitely turned idea from
academia or Hassen so I decided January
2015 to give me some wiggle room for the
2015 period in case you know they
basically would publish something that
year or they haven't published something
just beforehand and then of course I
also parse all the timestamps so I could
extract the data first paper date of
last paper survival time in days and
average publication time now of course
there's some errors in this approach
because maybe when you polish your first
paper you were in your masters or maybe
if you publish your first paper you were
already one year two years into your PhD
so of course there's gonna be this sort
of like plus minus 1 year error the
masters I actually
sorted it out by counting the number of
papers but anyway that's details but at
the end of this very long story you end
up with a ginormous data frame one row
per author which has all the information
that you want and it's also I'm feeling
- you feel like you have a chip this
thing
oh here's essentially some of the
comments that I mentioned before
cross-listing and they were of course
I'm obvious because because of the cross
listing issue say that you participated
on this ginormous collaborations like
like oh then those papers have like
gasoline authors so then you just go and
say Oh first like number of authors on
first paper 127 and you're like hmm so
if I want a model with a covariance
saying the impact of the number of
papers on your PhD or number of cores
and your PhD and basically you have all
this huge ginormous numbers that's a big
earlier so then you have to basically
try to sub-sector your data further in
order to get a good description of the
population as a whole so we kept outers
to have reasonable numbers quote unquote
so average number of callers is less
than six which was I looked at the
percentiles and they just decided okay
this makes sense less than 190 effective
papers effective means that basically
was not one of these ginormous
collaborations able to determine their
PhD affiliation that people that had
more than one paper that the average
publication time was less than five
years the number of papers is less than
185 and the number of quasars in their
first paper is less than 20 and the
number of papers our PhD is less than 30
to 32 so we were left with a sample of
4244 authors and then we created some
derived features because I wanted to
analyze this covariance so buckets for
co-authors cause the first paper average
publication time all this came all these
features election came almost from
experience and for me understanding how
how it works
i i basically classified authors and
assigned genders using the genderized
io api so basically have a huge state of
database of names and then they give you
if it's female or male with some
probability there's
a flag if you are independent researcher
or a more collaborative one based on do
you know the ratio of number of solo
papers versus papers with more authors
censoring flag top university which was
generated by listing the top 20
universities in the sample and create a
flag if the author's PhD was was from
one of these and these are the ones that
appeared just from my analysis but then
there's some caveats about the names
because of what I told you so we were
left with this total 3220 could be
assigned a gender and 760 of these were
flagged as having done their PhD in a
top university and this is some
interesting data nuggets so the gender
ADL ten percent female sixty-six percent
male twenty four percent on determine a
look actually the percentage for females
much more or less because some
probabilities associated with those
names are actually quite low so for
instance it classified an India as
female and most of them were Indian and
I know for a fact they were male so you
get this type of quirks Asian names also
were very tricky to guess so
so yes that is an issue the average
number of papers during the PhD was 5.2
which I thought it was quite high
however it has been decreasing in last
five years towards for the field from
you know stands at five and for male
five points are they have equivalent
number of quarters on their first paper
also with the non probability of gender
matching to be over eighty percent the
difference is wider and sample size
decreases from forty four hundred thirty
three two three four nine and some other
some other types of nuggets so ok tools
so if you're gonna do survival analysis
you can go to Python engines Google
survival Python and you probably find
can Davidson pylons lifelines which is a
very good library is built on top of
pandas includes nonparametric estimators
regression and various utility functions
so and the API is very similar to second
learn so you can basically start doing
stuff out of the box in art there's like
huge amount so but huge so I just put
some of the most visible ones but
there's too many and but in that page
there's like summary of everything
a library that you can find so let's
application so again a PhD comic talking
about difference between interning and
postdocs so here are basically my
estimates using the data I pull out for
the survival and hazard and the hazard
curve the median life time here was of
approximately nine years and this is the
typical life lines call so you create
our fitter object you pass your
durations you pass your censoring flag
and then basically you fit it to the
data object and then you can plot it and
there's lots of functions that allow you
to obtain the median lifetime which are
just acting on the object so it's quite
straightforward basically here we see
how how this probability decreases of
course for the longer lifetimes will
have only contributions coming from
individuals with their PhDs on the early
2000s so there's less and less data for
this side of the curve whereas there's
more data on this side of the curve so
this are complementary complementary
boxes and and this is basically now
starting to split by different
covariance so here you have male and
female and and also you have the hazard
curve and then you have the lifetime so
nine point seven years for men and seven
for two years for women but the sample
for women I'd say that is very very
small so there's errors there this is
like for the top 20 universities and
it's quite fun to see what's going on
I basically visit for my own amusement
and usually later go and look at the
slides but Oxford is quite fable and in
other like in the Japanese universities
Tokyo and Kyoto you sort of like copy
like very upward falls and then it's
very stable so there might be some sort
of cultural explanations to try to see
why that's the case I don't know if
students there tend to stay there as
postdocs or they go abroad etc and then
of course you have factoring by the
different covariance so I bucketed the
average publication time and the number
of quarters so the general method is
published a lot and have
of quarters you have lots of quarters
you publish a lot so there's some
interdependence here and those are the
buckets and if I had more time I would
explain more but I have still a bit a
bit to go and this is basically number
how important over page papers on your
PhD so your hazard rate will be higher
if you do just one or two papers on your
PhD but if you did from 7 to 31 it's
much less though again publish a lot and
then that's the difference between doing
a PhD in a top university or not it's
very very close you can do the same
thing in our so this are the typical
libraries the survival library the cold
is very simple
this basically case this serve object
and then you just fit it and then you
plot it this is a wrapper on ggplot that
gives you that very very nice graph and
these are the type of objects that you
can find on the on the fitted object now
we've done this nonparametric estimates
but then we would like to be able to
construct this curse for individuals and
we would also like to do prediction
tasks so the tool of all trays is a Cox
model which is a proportional hazard
proportional hazard model so the most
interesting analysis salmon is the
relationship between survival and one or
more covariates so the simplest thing
you could try to do is to write the
hazard and this form so exponential of
some linear combination of functions and
this was then superseded by Cox model
which leaves the baseline function so
that alpha are separate and unspecified
so that's why it's called
semi-parametric because that is
completely free and it will be just
fitted according to the data that you
have and so then basically you just have
your baseline hazard and variations of
one unit on each curve variate will have
a multiplicative effect on the baseline
hazard so that's what that expression is
telling you and to estimate this model
Cox introduced a method called partial
likelihood that I'm not gonna bore you
with but that's what life lifelines uses
to estimate or and fit the model there's
also another other types of models like
the active hazard models
so when the covariates are time
dependent and you can't use the Cox
model you can use this one so basically
you have a you know like scalar products
so that's why it's additive model and
the matrix why uses all the risk
information and the vector alpha
contains all the covariant regressors so
then you can basically build an estimate
for the hazard rate so this is again
applying the Cox model to a very very
dumb combination of models so here I
just use the number of PhD papers and
the number of authors and your first
paper ask covariance I use the patsy
library and python that allows you to
write r like formulas it's like one hot
encoding like dumb very quickly but you
can also do interaction terms out of the
box so then this is this is the summary
and here you can basically start making
statements uh such as you know if you do
the here the baselines are individuals
who have two or four papers during their
PhD with one or two authors in their
first paper so this tells me that if you
have number an individual has a number
of papers or a PhD on the one and two
bucket who have one point forty five
times the hazard rate over the baseline
so you can make statements as to the
difference in risk depending on the
different values of the cooperate with
respect to the baseline so if you have
the years a factor with two thousand
being the baseline we find an individual
starting on 2010 has two times the
hazard rate so he'll be more less likely
to survive if you are gender with female
being the baseline we find that a man
has point not 91 times the hazard rate
and well but building a model much more
complicated with gender quaters bucket
publication average bucket and
university you find other interesting
tidbits
so like the baseline of cambridge
university and if your female number of
authors in first papers zero two or
quasars buckets from two to three point
four you can basically make statements
about the relative hazard between
different institutions or between
different numbers of papers of different
cultures so have five minutes left
according to my
i phone so long performance so you can
give the concordance index to evaluate
model which is a generalization of the
area under the ROC curve and as a
callback to my first pi day to London
I'm going to explain it using my
favorite show on TV so consider all
possible pairs of patients at least one
of whom has died so hi Geoffrey so then
you take a pair of patients and then if
you predict the survival time for John
and this happens to be larger than the
predicted survival time for Geoffrey you
call this concordant with the outcome
and if you pick another pair patients
but the predicted survival time for
Danny is less than the predicted
survival time for Geoffrey then you have
the anti cortical anti concordant would
outcome so you can basically compute
this index and 0.5 would be your
concordance index if you have random
observations and basically if you do
cross validation of the model that I
presented before you get that your
models I'll have a concordance and index
up around 0.6 the 8.69 so so this means
that is performing well and then this is
the equivalent for R and oh this is
something called it's a sure no
residuals and it's to test if the
potus's of your Coburn's not varying
with time is true and of course it's not
true so that's why you use the Allen
model and very very quickly what happens
if you want to apply this technique to
very very big datasets if you actually
go and see the implementation of how you
compute the Cox model or both an hour
and Python you see that it's actually
quite intensive so if you want to run it
for a very very big data set and for
covariance that have lots of levels
namely categorical variables it will
take forever and you are probably you
won't be able to do it so then you hit a
wall so then you have to find other
projects to give an estimation of the
survival curve so you can use
generalized additive models which I was
going to explain but of course I'm gonna
be running out of time and you can just
think logistic regression and that will
give you already the gist of what you're
doing you have a link function and then
you
a linear combination of function smooth
functions that are alike splines and
then you can fit a baseline hazard on it
so I'm gonna skip this but essentially
in our there's a library called M GC b
and this implements Gamson art but it
has a function called BAM that is a
special for big big big datasets and you
can paralyze in different clusters so
basically you can build your gam and you
can actually build an estimate for the
survival curve so these are the typical
calls the other thing you can do is you
can use random survival for us so the
library random forests SRC basically has
now koalas if you've used random forest
an R for either classification or
regression tasks then you already know
how to do it but instead of having you
know your categorical data or your
numerical data now you have durations
data and it's the same type of course
the bonus points for this type of
approach is basically that you only have
to fix three parameters the number of
randomly selected predictors the number
of trees to grow and the splitting rule
and there's no assumptions about
proportional hazards or time dependent
covariance or anything so you can just
go and play with it immediately and just
train your forests and so this is the
typical call it's exactly the same if
you don't run the forest before and then
I basically did the same model for the
Cox model so you could then compare it
but this is basically for the training
set it evaluates every single survival
curve for all your individuals and then
those are the predictions for the test
set so I've just plotted them for you so
those are all people in academia that
might with their probabilities of
remaining or not and you can also get
very very variable importance of a
freebie so here it says that the number
of pages on your PhD is the most
important variable in order to basically
predict you know survival probability
then the number of call the average
number of quarters that you have in your
papers so if you have again lots of
quarters that's a good thing that the
PhD place etc etc so in my
last 40 seconds I'm just gonna give you
a very quick TL DR so surviving academia
nine years is the median academic life
and this is roughly equivalent to a PhD
and probably one or two postdocs
depending on the length of your postdocs
lots of papers during your PhD are a
good indicator of survival so publish or
die be a good networker so many
collaborations equals many papers and
opportunities then choosing the right
place for a PhD helps because probably
it facilitates the creation of networks
and finally the data is consistent with
trends of women in stem so but the
sample size for women was very very
small on survival analysis this
extremely useful technique is applicable
to many problems in various fields
there's a very good Python library with
estimators and regressors thanks camped
out some pilot more stuff available in
art so gowns random survival forest and
there's other approached patient and
there was a tutorial in the subject
yesterday that I hope you didn't miss
and thanks well there were some that
events that were observable because
basically if I didn't see any paper like
forever after a while assume that that
person was that so basically if I didn't
have served that event after the 2015
like cutoff that I introduced then I
would consider that probably that person
was still alive and then I consider as
being a censored observation but there
was a decision I made based on
experience of being an academic and
knowing you know if people don't publish
in two years they're probably just out
so and then in order to test that
hypothesis I look at my population and
looked at you know the distribution of
publication times to see if that was
actually a sensible decision to make but
yeah what you're suggesting might be
another view but I didn't explore that
so I stick with my original decision
in retail so I guess you know customer
churn would be a popular one if you do
email marketing in first and lists we're
looking at auto stock prediction we sell
clothes so that's an interesting one to
basically predict when products will go
out of stock if you're developing
because I said it has applications and
failure if you are building products
that they are basically gonna like
washing machines or stuff and you're
selling that you might want to know when
people will be likely to buy another one
so you might want to market to them so I
don't know exactly which I mean within
retail exactly what we're talking about
but I say that there's many many
different applications in terms of for
instance retail or in e-commerce
particularly you can look at you know
trying to model you know from
registration to first use or if you're
running a membership services like how
long will they remain a subscriber
before they basically quit their
subscription because then you might want
to predict when to send them an email to
say don't go this is an amazing offer so
I think in market we didn't retail and
marketing those are the most natural
applications but there might be others
yeah yeah you're totally correct yeah
so that's why I took this uh yeah it
you're totally right
I took the stepwise approach because I
knew a priority that some features were
likely to be heavily correlated like for
instance the co-authors with the number
of papers which is why I didn't look at
the number of papers and just like the
number of papers during your PhD because
suddenly at the very least I was
demanding that you have two papers and
there's a huge amount of people that in
their PhD they only do two papers so as
I was like my minimal requirement and
there was I said like oh this is my
initial feature and I don't I don't want
to know about the rest because then that
would be feedback in tomorrow there's
other features that one could try to do
but I would say that because of the
complexity of just getting the data
together that's the hard thing to do but
it's something that uh for instance
citations or like other type of networks
and there's different things that one
can think of but you're totally right
so this was meant more of us I can you
know exploratory fun thing oh thank you
no you're totally right yes
so in the context of this particular one
it's hard to say because this data set
was rather small so in terms of like
speed performance or like there's really
nothing that you could say in terms of
accuracy maybe but I didn't really run
many different types of template did
like parameter optimization within the
random for us to be able to say I found
the optimal parameters and random for us
that basically break call performance
but the point that I was making here is
actually if you just in like random
forests in general they're like your
Swiss Army knife like I don't know
anything let's try this and see because
I know it's robust it doesn't tell it
doesn't tend to overfit and the fact is
that because of what I explained even
though I use the Cox model in principle
I should have used a Cox model because
this covariance vary in time so then you
would need to do another approach and in
run the forest you don't need to make
this type of assumptions so but I've
read a couple of papers where they say
that in some scenarios actually the
vanilla Cox model works better than the
random forest whereas in other scenarios
when you particularly when you have time
variable covariance then it's a very
good but very good technique but the
survival random forests are very recent
so I don't even know if there's an
implementation in Python I don't think
there is so I would be hard position to
give you a concrete answer for this
question
thank you
because we don't hold an inventory at
lists so that's basically it we know
very little about our the products that
a retailers hold so we don't have all
that extra information
we literally have time stamps so that's
the main motivation I'm gonna share the
slides which have all the snippets and
I'll be putting the code extract that
they don't get half later on I need to
clean it a little bit so and I'll send
the link to the organizers when the time
comes
sorry I'm published well in many cases
these are actually unpublished because
prints are not necessarily published in
a journal and I actually didn't didn't
want to get into one feature extra
feature that I could have considered
well instead of just looking at total
number of papers your paper is really
print but a print could be a conference
proceeding it could be a serious or
notes that someone wrote for a lecture
it could mean it many things so you
could partition that for instance for
the type of journal that you published
because there will be a measure of the
impact factor that that you know
publication had and those will be other
features but it was more like you know
how they say that there's this cliche
and data science that 90% of the time
you spend doing cleaning and data and
preparing your data and 10% of the time
so this is perfect example of that but
yeah you could do that
Oh totally
actually I was doing some NLT using NLT
K to do some text analysis on the
abstracts to look at you know like the
words and like and you get I mean in hap
th you get all of course lots of string
theory super gravity so of course the
progressive is very high and although
sort of worse I didn't think baby Luke
up here like 30 or 40 after removing all
the stop words but you can build
features from that as well I guess so
that would be a fun thing to do yeah
definitely
so that's why I said like you have put
the stuff in github maybe people can go
and play with the data there because I
don't have enough time to do so